welcome students faculty and staff to
the sexual violence response open house
my name is Laura sure bro and I am
honored to be one of 14 peer advocates
who would like to welcome you all to our
new workspace a sexual violence response
and rape crisis anti-violence support
center is a department here on campus
that's a part of columbia health that
does advocacy work prevention and
outreach to support and address issues
of gender-based sexual and intimate
partner violence on columbia's campus
we're looking at trying to change and
have an impact on culture we really need
to have various activities informing
policies and even having very clear
specific trainings in curriculum you
know available to support a community's
understanding of how to prevent these
behaviors that that means a new student
initiative to help prevent sexual
violence on campus and a very active and
proactive way where students get
involved students say something students
make sure that everyone around them is
safe their friends are safe and it's
really a great way to have students have
a sudden what's happening on campus
because sexual violence isn't a problem
between the perpetrator and the victim
sexual violence is a problem for every
single person in the community that
occurs in and so we are all responsible
for making sure that it is not part of
our community and that it's not welcome
here step up really is a model of
educating students to become pro-social
bystanders it's something that we engage
not only our students with but even
employees on campus so it is an effort
to really integrate within our current
programs and our current efforts on
campus to really synergize how do we
provide these intervention skills that
are very concrete and very often times
for many people feel kind of simple to
really do on a day-to-day basis and
really identify how can I utilize these
skills to potentially prevent an
incident from occurring or to disrupt
problematic behavior and or even to have
those moments of you know I couldn't
respond in the way that I want it to but
how can I follow up with this person and
have the capacity to do that and the
resources to do that and so that's what
bystander intervention training does and
that's what step up does I think
stepping up is something that is a
generational struggle because it gets
right to the issue of apathy and a fith
II is something that you've often been
conditioned to do because it's so much
easier to be passive and not to take a
stance and just to remain doing s you
already do we're as stepping up
requiring advocacy requiring that active
step that Colombia promotes within its
community we ask students to step up
within their academic fields we ask
students to step up as leaders all the
time it's another to Matt aspect of
stepping up where we ask students to now
step up within a social sphere to take
care of their fellow students to take
care of other individuals in the
community so stepping up is something
that I think Columbia students have been
told repeatedly throughout their lives
it's just a particular context that we
have to be aware of in this case step up
can help stop sexual violence on campus
because instead of thinking a friend
will say something maybe someone else
will do something you are actively
getting involved in a situation that
feels unsafe to you part of the program
is to have students realize that like
who are you in the situation you can
always be someone who helps I think a
lot of people really want to do things
in situations but might just not know
how I think step up provide people with
tools that they can use to engage and by
step up and this whole bystander
intervention we can create a community
where people feel safe and supported
step up in campus-wide means that we all
enter this community with the same
standards will enter with the same
education and so we all are able to
recognize unsafe situations when they
happen and that no one is ever alone or
it's dangerous situation without helpful
without helpful people and friends
around if we create a culture in which
we promote the education and promote the
the understanding that individuals have
certain rights that are never to be
violated or never to be disrespected it
creates that mentality within students
to understand that we ought to and
should
backed individuals